Selamlar sevgili arkadaşlar. Umarım
iyisiniz. Sağlık sıat yerinde. Eee iş
arıyorsanız güzel iş fırsatları sizinle
olmuştur. eee şayet bir ekipte
çalışıyorsanız da emeğinizin hakkının
karşısını alıyor. Sizi anlayan
yöneticileriniz vardır. Eee ve umarım
mutlu bir ekiple çalışıyorsunuzdur. Bu
hayatta en güzel şey mutlu bir ekiple
çalışmak gerçekten. Eee şimdi bugün
arkadaşlar sizlerle birlikte aslında
biraz böyle bir VB10 tarzı daha böyle
kısası daha sakin olan bir içeriğe
başlayacağız. Bu içerikteki amacım da
aslında şu oldu. Tabii güncel durumları
da en çok işimize yarayacak noktaları da
referans almak istediğim için ne
yapabilirim diye düşündüğümde aklıma
şöyle bir şey geldi. En çok bizim
kullandığımız bu ara en çok popüler olan
başlıklardan ve bence gerçekten değer
katacak bir işten bir tanesi. Dedim ki
bugüne kadar gördüğüm bir proje
hazırlayayım. İşte AI based bir proje
hazırladım burada. E ve aklıma
gelebilecek en kötü veya belki
muhtemelen bundan daha kötüsü vardır ama
e olabilecek en kötü, olmayacak en
yapılmaması gereken hiçbir best
practicein veya hiçbir şey gördüğünüz
gibi olmayan tek düzey isimlendirmeler
en azından bir tık iyi bunların daha
kötüsünü görüyoruz olan bir proje
hazırladım. Ve bu projeyi de arkadaşlar
birlikte böyle 5 10 tane böyle küçük
küçük videolarla birlikte refactör
edeceğiz. Adımları böyle bir iş olsaydı
nasıl yapardınızı? Bunların hepsini tek
tek konuşarak arkadaşlar birlikte
yapıyor olacağız. Bu da bunun ilki.
İlkinde de arkadaşlar amacımız analiz.
Yani böyle bir projeye geldiğimizde
özellikle bu tarz işlerdeki en büyük
problem doğrudan koda girmek oluyor.
Koda girmeden önce ne yapmalıyız? Nasıl
bakmalıyız? Nelere bakmalıyızı şöyle bir
ufak hep birlikte inceleyelim. Eee
konuşalım. Ondan sonrasından da yeni
videolarda da bu konuştuklarımızın
fikslerini işte yapılarını ekliyor
olacağız. Eee sevgili arkadaşlar dediğim
gibi buradaki amacım tamamen eee çok
gerçek bir projeyi yani gerçek
olabilecek bir projeyi referans ederek
size aslında yeni bir projeye
başladığınızda yol göstermek. Ondan
dolayı eee yapacağımız fixler de bu
arada tamamen advance seviyede olmasına
dikkat edeceğim. Yani bir tık ileri
seviye yapmaya çalışacağım ki size bir
fikir versin. Açılsın projenizde. E bu
projede arka tarafta custom backend de
hazırladım. Onu da dart'la yazdım. Hatta
dart tarafıyla hazırlattım ki hani
doğrudan bir dart flutter projesiyle
aslında hazırlanmış bir endpinti olan
bir backende istek de attığımız yani
birebir gerçek hayatın örneği bir proje
olduğunu tekrardan söylemiş olayım.
Şimdi gelin birlikte analiz kısmında
böyle projeyi gördüğünüz neler yapmanız
gerekiyoru konuşalım. Ben zaten burada
bir to diye bir dosya oluşturdum.
Arkadaşlar tamam mı? Bu Tudu dosyası
zaten size yol gösterecek ışık yani size
bir eee fikir ve anlam verecek. Yarın
başlasanız bu TUDakinin tabii ki bir tık
daha iler ve projesine göre olanı olur
ama 3 aşağı 5 skora bu y tamla ilerlemek
bize faydalı olacak. Şimdi arkadaşlar,
eee, bir Flutter projesine başladığınız
noktada veya bir projeye girdiğiniz
noktada her zaman için şu şeyi kontrol
edeceğim de video doğru video çekiliyor.
Eee, hemen akla gelen bu arada projeyi
de şöyle bir refresh edeyim, göstereyim.
Şöyle flight Booking adına şöyle bir app
hazırlattım aslında. Şöyle user.test.com
deyip 1 2 3 4 5 6 deyince AP'ye istek
atıyor. Datalar şöyle bir data
setlerimiz var. İşte şöyle bir sayfamız
var. Burada da işte çıkış yapıyor, giriş
yapıyor falan gibi böyle. Aslında bakalı
da Yay anlamında a okey o kadar kötü
değil diyorsun ama en azından yani bir
akış bir şeyler var ama arka taraf
gerçekten hiçbir eee yani tasvir
etmeyeceğimiz belki onlarca yol dolu.
Bununla da konuşuyor olacağız. Şimdi
burada arkadaşlar birlikte bu tarz bir
projeye başladığınızda ne yapmalıyızın
ilk noktası? Bunlarla ilgili birçok
nokta olabilir ama hep böyle bir state
management üzerine bir nokta geliyor. Bu
değil. Hiçbir state management paketi
doğrudan bir projeye performans etkisi
öyle tak diye yapmaz. Projenin
içerisinde o kadar çok bağımlılıklar ve
o kadar çok yapılması gereken nokta
vardır ki bunlar hazırlanmadan bir
paketten medet de beklenmez. Böyle
olursa zaten çok paket bazlı bilmem nezı
işler oluyor. Neyse ona girmeden ben
şimdi zaten şu to'dakini şu sol tarafa
aldım. Okumak amacıyla ne zaman sırayı
kaybetmeyelim diye ben sırayla size
nasıl başlamanız gerektiğini anlatıyor
olacağım. Ben burada birincisi olarak
arkadaşlar bu projelere girdiğimde hiç
sıralara girmeden bir PUB SPEC'e
giriyorum. Tamam mı? Ya PU SPEC'te
aradığım şey ne diyeceksiniz?
Pubspack'te aradığım şey şu. Kullanılan
paketler. E burada mesela kullanılan
asetlerin isimlendirmeleri. Eee ondan
sonra mesela onları da böyle bozuk bozuk
hazırlattım hatta. Eee sonrasında linter
anlamında neler kullanılmış? Eee
paketler kullanılırken acaba paketler şu
şekilde hashtag'l ayrılıp mesela core ya
da işte backend ya da işte database
şeklinde ayrılmalar yapılmış mı? Eee ve
burada bir de tabii ki bazen görüyorum
mesela şöyle kullanımlar oluyor, eniler
oluyor. Bunlar ne kadar var mesela?
Pubspack Yamal'dan projenin önce bir eee
3 be aşağıya ne olduğunu anlayabiliy
mesela şöyle alt alta işte şuralar boş
veya buradaki isimlendirmelere
baktığınız an ya da şu zaten şunlar
duruyorsa zaten bir şey de anlatıyor da
eee bir hemen direkt kafanızda bir şey
beliriyor. Yani projenin aslında en
önemli kısmının aslında çok e üst üste
veya karmaşık gitme problemi oluşmuş
duruyor. Şimdi birincisi burası
arkadaşlar. Yani projenin eee alt
katmanın eee şey projenin paketlerinin
aslında doğru pubpack yamal tarafı en
önemse tarafının doğru kurgulanmamış
olması. Yani buradaki yapılması
gerekenleri de yine konuşuyor olacağız.
Şu an sadece ben fikir ve hataları görme
anlamında söylüyorum. Şimdi burayı
yaptıktan sonra en çok burada gördüğümüz
şu bende otomatik oluyor bu arada. Sizde
olmazsa da onu paylaşacağım. Onla da
arkada maddem var. Eee hatta onunla
ilgili şurada bir yerde bakayım.
yapılarımda olması lazım. Eee, project
şurada da şuraya ekleyeyim. VS code
settings
project etc diye. Şimdi ikincisi
arkadaşlar analiz option. Şimdi bak şu
analiz option'ı şöyle gördüğüm an
diyorum ki zaten haydi geldik cenaze
namazına diyorum. Çünkü yani burada e
arkadaşlar bu analiz option yam zaten o
projenin o takımın e en ortak noktası ve
projenin analiz edil yani kodlarının
hangi şekilde yürüyeceğini neye
engelleyeceğimizi mesela işte rurlar
yazarak buraya buraya bazı exceptionlar
bazı kriteryalar koyarak işte mesela
empty kod bıraktım bunun prda di
otomatik işte error olmasını vesaire bir
sürü parametreyi burada handle
yapabildiğimiz kısmı boş bıraktığımızda
veya doğrudan flutterın ın kendimize
verdiğini kullandığımızda oldukça
yetersiz. Yani bu bu daha doğrusu bu
basit bir linter. Yani içerisinde
kuralları var. Kendin kastimize de
edebiliyorsun ama eee paketler var.
Commuttin vesaire. Burayı yani Linter
yine projenin olmazsa olmaz ve o
projenin sağlıklı ilerleyebilmesi ve
PR'ların daha iyi olabilmesi adına en
güzel noktalarından bir tanesi de burada
yer alıyor arkadaşlar. Şimdi eee analiz
option yamalı ondan dolayı oldukça
önemli. Bir diğer noktada 3ünc maddeye
geçecek olursam ben geldiğimde şuna da
bakıyorum. Tabii bu takım çalışmalarında
bireyselde şimdi arkadaşlar şu noktaya
enfikir olmak lazım. Bireysel çalışırken
istediğin her şey yapabilirsin. Tabii
benim buradaki anlatmaya çalıştığım o
değil. Benim buradaki anlatmaya
çalıştığım büyüyen, büyüyecek bir
projenin neleri düşünmesi gerektiği.
Yani hani ben bireyselde istediğini ver
isteyla bir şey çıkartırsın ortaya. O
beni ilgilendirmez. Burada 5 kişi, 10
kişi veya bir ekibe girdiğinde, bir
ekibi büyütmek istediğinde neleri
referans almalısın? Ben bunu anlatmaya
çalışıyorum. Ondan dolayı yani abi ona
da gerek yok noktası bende olabilecek
bir nokta değil. Olmalı ya bunların
hepsi hani kullanılmalı. Zorunda aslında
bir şekilde bunlar entegre ediliyor
olmalı. Eee şurada şey de entegre
edelim.
Tamam. Şimdi şu tohumu güncelledim de
son olarak. Hatta burada güncelledikten
sonra şuradaki toumu da düzelleyeyim.
Heh. Tamam. Buradan buradan devam
ediyorum. Bu arada arkadaşlar analiz
option'ı konuştum. Bir diğer maddem VS
settings eee ayarları. VS Code settings
ayarları. Şimdi şöyle bir şey var
projelerde tabii ki bu VS COD'dur, insan
IDelerdir, cursördür işte bir sürü ID
var şu an aktif kullanılan. Bunlar
önemli değil. Burada önemli olan hareket
şu. Mesela bakın benim işte VS kodumda
işte bir bir script kullanmışım. burayı
böyle yapıyor veya benim VS kodumda
buradaki settings yable'ım yok da
settingsle'da işte ben bir dosyaya gelip
bir mesela diyelim ki şurada bir tane
libin altında mesela bir test nokta dart
açtığımda işte ben burada class m bir
şeyler yaptığımda işte mesela bunun
içerisine void muid işte bir kod
yazdığımda otomatik olarak ne bileyim
save attığımda işte buradan
formatladığımda vesaire ya da şuradan
şöyle bir şeyler gördüğünüz gi otomatik
format diyor vesaire bunlar aslında idin
ayarları takım çalışmasında Aslında
bunlar da önemli aslında. Çünkü takım
aynı formatingleri, aynı işte line
kurallarını vesaire kurgularsa bu da o
takım için ileri bakış açılarından bir
tanesi olacaktır. Bunlar küçük küçük ama
hatayı minimize edecek ve aynı kodu,
aynı pi'ları almış. Şimdi bazen PR
görüyoruz arkadaşlar. Bir kod any'da,
bir kod Konya'da böyle PR'lar geliyor.
Mesela görmediğim bir şeyler değil.
Bunlar böyle takım e entegre edilmesi ve
konuşması gereken en en önemli
noktalardan bir tanesi olduğunu
söyleyebilirim. Şimdi bu da tabii ide
bazlı bunlar yapılabilir ama önemli olan
şey konfigürasyonun fontların bile ya
kişisel şeyler fonta girmeye gerek olmaz
ama birçok noktanın aynı olması. Yani
burada tabii ki hatta kullanılan
extension paketlerinin bile eee
bakıldığında eee mesela hani kullanılan
blokudur bir şey kullanıyorsanız
bunların bile belli seviyede aynı ve
aynı pakette aynı versiyonda olması
oldukça önemli. Yani takımın bir kokusu
olması lazım arkadaşlar. Ben bu advance
bir proje geliştiriyorsak yani gelişmiş
bir projenin eee bir kokusu olması
lazım. Gördüğünüz gibi burada öyle bir
koku yok. Ya bu projede şu an bireysel
olarak ben gözüküyorum ama e benim
yaptığım konfigürasyonlar, benim
extensionlarım bu gibi ilerleyecek. Bu
da ne olacak? Yeni gelen insanı
zorlayacak veya yeni gelen insan buraya
adapte olamayacak. Onun bir şey olacak.
Normalde takımda en önemli şey yeni
gelenin rahat adapte ve sensiz adapte
olabilmesi. Özellikle bir proje böyle
adapte olabiliyorsa mükemmel. E bunlar
olmadığı zaman da o zaman zaten o işte
bir sıkıntı olduğu aşikar oluyor. Şimdi
bunu da entegre ettik, konuştuk diyelim.
Bir sonraki kısım arkadaşlar benim en
çok önemsediğim yine bir gelişmiş proje
yapıyorsak flavorların olması gerekiyor.
Yani ne mesela ben burada flight booking
appim var. Tamam mı? Bakın şu noktada
yine yüzü yani artık zaten şu seviyede e
flutter'ın da konuştuk aylarca. Size
gelip bunları böyle dümenden ya da basic
anlatmanın anlamı yok. Burada şu noktada
hemfikri olmanız lazım ve şu fikri
almanız gerekiyor. Ben bir app
geliştiriyorsam ve bu app bireysel
app'ler için konuşmuyorum. dediğim gibi
büyüyecek, büyük çaplı ekiple çalıştıran
applede mesela Flight Bookings appim. Bu
Flight Booking appinin muhakkak bir
development versiyonu olması lazım. Bu
development versiyonu ne demek? Yani
flight booking dev gibi mesela. Bu dev
bana ne avantaj sağlayacak diyeceksiniz.
Ben devde bazı şeyleri enable edeceğim.
Mesela loglamaları, mesela bazı
featur'ları sadece devde açık
bırakacağım ve production'da bunları
kapatacağım. Şimdi burada şöyle bir şey
konuşuluyor. Abi diyor hani mesela
flavor yapmayalım. Şurada bir butona
bağlayalım. Buna göre açıp kapatalım.
Bakın şu fikre gelmiş olmanız lazım.
Müşteriye yani sizin son kullanıcıya
vereceğiniz client daima test ediliyor.
Şimdi bu test yapılırken eee ve bu teste
göre işlemler yapılırken bir butona
basıp işte bir şeyi aç bir butona
olmaması lazım. Yani bu ne demek
istiyorum? Senin flavorları entegre
ederek uygulamanın birtım şemalarını
oluşturup yeni bir ortamını oluşturup
işte development ve production diye
ayırarak sen ne yapıyorsan yap
development'ta ve production olan
environment'ın asla dokunmaman
gerekiyor. Yani production envirment
daima senin en son kullanıcıya gidecek
ol. Bunu başarabilirsen için kafan rahat
olur. Ama yok bana dersen ki ben şu
butonu şuna koyacağım. Bunu buradan
alacağım. Bunun zaten açıkçası e
yapılmaması. Yani bunu yapabilirsin.
Teknik olarak her şey yapılabilir. Mevzu
bahis burada teknik olarak yapılmak
değil. Mevzu bahis burada açık
bırakmamak. Çünkü ben biliyorum ki bunu
bir butona bağlandı. Bir checkbox'a
bağladığında takımından bir kişi bu
hatayı yapabilir ve gözünden kaçmaz
gider. Ondan dolayı bunu baştan
kapatıyor olman lazım. Yani development
ve production applerine ayırmayı da bu
tarz bir büyük projede konuşuyor olmak
lazım. Şimdi devam ediyorum arkadaşlar.
Bir diğer maddemizde tabii biz bunu kısa
dedik ama bu iyi ki bir uzun olur.
Diğerleri daha kısa olur. E Flavor'ı
konuştuk. Bir diğer de paketler kontrol
edecek. Şimdi burada kullandığımız
paketler var. Tabii bakın şimdi burada
önemli kullanacağımız şey paketleri niye
kullandık? Hangi paketler ne
avantajımıza suyor veya ihtiyacımız
olmayan paketler var mı? Paketler
outdated mı? Hepsi güncelliğini almış
mı? Bunları kontrol ediyor olmamız
lazım. Bir de arkadaşlar burada benim
yine size vereceğim mesela gelişmiş
düşüncelerde paketleri kontrol edelim. E
mesela burada işte bazı olmazsa olmaz
işte belki EQ table paket olmazsa olmaz
olur gerçi de mesela bir e belki
cashingle alakalı paketlerden veya işte
burada bir servis zaten eklenmiş ama
belli başlı işte Jason paketlerinden,
Mapper paketlerinden bunlar olmalı. Eee
o eksik olan paketleri bir referans
etmek lazım ki bu referansa göre projeyi
ileri götürmek lazım. Burada en önemli
olan şeylerden bir tanesi arkadaşlar ben
size tricky bir pointla bu hatayı ben de
bazen yapıyorum. Mesela bir teste
başlıyorsunuz ve brenci de aslında
konuşmak lazım da brenç biraz daha başka
bir başlık. Diyelim ki başladığınız
testte şöyle bir şapka var. Şapka ne
oluyor aslında? Eğer bir az üst
versiyonu varsa pgcet attığınızda veya
clean atıp bir şey yaptığınızda ona
kendini otomatik güncellemiş oluyor.
Böyle atarsanız 420'ı daimi alıyor.
Şimdi burada şu practice gelebiliyor
olmamız lazım. Bizim biz release paketi
çıkıyorsak ve teste başladıysak bu
420'dır ve Flutter'ın diyelim ki 1
versiyonunda çalışıyordur. Eğer biz buna
şapka atarsak mesela diyelim ki test
versiyonu 1 ay sürdü. Bir ayın sonuna 4
2 1 çıktıysa o 4 2 1 gidiyor olacak.
Bakın bunlar o kadar önemli şeyler ki
yani müşteriye vereceğiniz test
paketinin içerisindeki bazı şeylerin bir
versiyonunda abi bir şey olmaz bir
versiyon artmış dememek lazım. Bunları
bakın ben de zamanda bu hataları yaptım.
Bu hataları yapmama adına ve projenin
tabii ki durumuna ve sizin de takip
etmenize göre e aslında bu şapkaları
release paketlerinde kaldırıp
development'a geri geldiğinizde açmanız
lazım. Paketlerin en önemli kısmından
bir tanesi bu. Yani development'a
release paketindeyken bir versiyonu
freeze ediyorsunuz aslında. Yani ben
diyorsun ki Deoon'un 5,32'yi referans
alıyorum. Yeni bir şey gelmesi noktası
devde olmalı. Fakat bu freeze yapmazsan
sıkıntı.
Ha tabii de işte burada kullanmamız
gereken best practice paketleri de yine
senin bu arada şimdi best practice
paketler şöyledir. Ben bir şey söylerim,
sen bir şey söylersin. Bu hep böyle
değişir ama mesela responsive size çok
popülerdir. Kullanılır. Device preview
bence olmazsa olmazlardan yani böyle bir
sürü paketler yine sayabilirim. Ya da
işte en büyük paketlerden işte ben
mesela Very good'un Linter'ını çok
seviyorum. Linter hizmetleri ya burada
belki adını sayamayacağım bir sürü paket
var. O içeriği şekle size anlatacağım.
hangi paketleri kullandım ben kendi yine
o bana bana göre olacak bu arada çünkü
sen belki daha iyisini biliyorsundur
veya seni daha bu fark etmez ama burada
bu kavramların hangi paketleri
kullanıyoruz veya niye kullanıyoruz
farkında olmanız lazım. Ve son olarak
arkadaşlar gerçekten iyi bir proje
geliştiriyor ve projede sabit yani
projede kaliteli iş yapmak istiyorsanız
eee yani şöyle şu düşünün arkadaşlar bir
yemek yiyorsanız ve yemeği kaliteli
yemek istiyorsanız yemeğin nasıl
yapıldığını anlamak istersiniz. Pudur.
Bunun mutfağı görmek istersin mesela.
Mutfağını gördüğünde mutlu olursun.
Temizdir veya şefin yaptığını
anlayabilirsen belki öyle mutlu olursun.
Veya içinde neler var bunları bilirsen
mutlu olursun. Yani benim zaten bununla
ilgili kanallar oluşturduğum paket oku
paket okuma diye bir seri var. Yani
aslında buradaki bir praktis de şudur.
Ekip oluyorsanız kullandığınız bütün
paketlere not düşersiniz. Bu arada open
source paketler aslında release de
yazmanız gerekiyor. Başka bir nokta da
eee kullandığınız bütün paketlere not
düşersiniz ve paketleri haftalık olarak
ekiple bir işue listesinden kontrol
edersiniz. Mesela Flutter'ın Firebase
core paketinin işte hadi bu haftaki
kontrollerini yaptık. 5 işsue açılmış 3
bu yapılmış. Ekipçede bir tane PR review
yaptık gibi. Mesela bunu yapıyorsanız
var ya o projeden hiç korkmazsınız.
Çünkü ben şunu çok duyuyorum. Yani 10
defa kullanılıyor paketler. Bir
versiyonda Shared Preferences'in bilmem
ne güncellemesi geliyor falan. Onu diyor
ki ya abi diyor paketten çalışmıyor. E
kardeşim 5 yıldır paket çalışıyordu. Sen
bu işten para kazandın. O yolunu buldun.
Demedin ki bir gün lan sen niye bugüne
kadar çalıştın al sana bu önden diye. Ya
bu pakette de sana yapacağını yapmış.
Yani bunlar da yine aslında o kadar
güzel şeyler ki yolla zamanla ekiple ama
dediğim gibi bu tarz şeyler bireysel
olması çok zor. Ekip kontenjan durum
önemli. Fakat sen çalıştığın kurumu
benim gibi anlatırsan eminim ki sana bu
performansı verir. Çünkü şu da var. Yani
ben bunu yapacağım deyim dümenden
geçenler de olacaktır. Eee bu da bir
başlık. Şimdi arkadaşlar bir nokta
projeye doğru yavaş yavaş geçiyorum.
Hani proje öncesini konuşmuş olduk.
Projeye geçtikten sonrasında arkadaşlar
main dart kontrol ya benim gerçekten ilk
baktığım yer burası oluyor. Main dart.
Bakın daha şu ana kadar gram state
management konuşmadık. Yani benim
flutter projelerinde gördüğüm en komik
şey o. Yani hiçbir şey bilmeyen de bilen
de sözüm ona ilk hemen şey yapıyor. Abi
hangi state management paketini kullanir
falan ya hiçbirinin birbirinden farkı
inanın bana. Tabii ki kalemlerde
performans farkları çıkacaktır. Bir
onlarla ilgili bir şeyler paylaşacağım o
içerikte 34 tane paterni kullanmayı
anlatacağım ama önemli olan şey
gerçekten yüzlerce kullanım varken
bunları kaçırıp sadece bir pakete
bağımlı iş olmaz. Bunun aklınızda otsun.
Main dart'a girdimde arkadaşlar burada
tabii ben gerçekten şöyle Main Dart'ın
onlarca satır kodu olduğunu çok defa
gördüm. Main'te bizim önemli olan dikkat
etmemiz gereken nokta Runup'ten önceki
yaptığımız işlemlerin projenin o ilk
splash sayfasıyla ilk projenin açıldığı
app launchunun arasındaki duran durun o
bomboş time olduğunu unutmadan elimizden
geldiği kadarıyla mainartın runap
öncesini clear etmemiz lazım. İhtiyaç
olmayan her şeyi splashit etmemiz lazım.
Ondan sonra main dart'ın içerisinde
tabii şu kodların hiçbiri olmaması
gerekiyor. Yani bunlar splash'te veya
alt metotlarda. Ve burada diyelim ki siz
arkadaşlar main dart içerisinde bir
işlem yapıyorsunuz. Bu yaptığınız
işlemleri en kötü çapta part part part
part part of diyerek main özel
ayırabilirsiniz. Ve bu mainde de yine
eee kullandığınız paket veya
kullandığınız duruma göre mainin de
development mainini falan filan da
oluşturuyoruz duruma göre. Ben orada onu
söyleyeyim. Main'deki en önemli konu bu.
Mainde dikkat etmeniz gereken en önemli
noktalardan bir tanesi de crashleri
yakalamak. E bazı initializ'larda mesela
şurada diyelim initialized bir crash
olabiliyor. Burada crash olması demek
runapin çalışmaması anlamına geliyor.
Ondan dolayı buralarda safety darmakta
fayda var. Şimdi bunu konuştuk tabii ki
geldik arkadaşlar tema ve constant
padingler kontrol edecek. Şöyle birkaç
sayfaya gittiğinizde zaten e benim
muhtemelen kendi kodlarını görüyor
olacaksın. İşte preference'lar elle
yazılmış. Analitikler burada. View
kodları burada. Şimdi bakın, eee,
buradaki içeriye geldiğimde biraz daha
onu anlatacağım ben size. Todo şöyle
sabitleyeyim de. Şimdi ben daha
anlatacağım size. Burada önemli olan
hareket şu arkadaşlar. Bizim böyle bir
projeyi refactör edeceğimiz zaman da
nasıl edeceğimizi de anlatacağım ama eee
hiçbir şekilde hiçbir projede mesela
burada 30 diyelim ki sağdan 20 alttan 30
mesela bir sağdan aşağı 30 burada 20 de
şurada 30 padding var şurada 20 padding
var gibi bir şey olamaz. Projenin bütün
kokusun bir olması gerekiyor. Renk
setlerinden kalır temasına kadar işte
sizeının belli bir dün katları mesela
çok popülerdir. Kullanılmasından tutun
vesaire. Bunların hepsinin bir akışta
olması gerekiyor. Bu akış yoksa ki zaten
burada gördüğünüz gibi bunların
hiçbirinde bunlar yok. Buradaki
page'lerde de yok bu akışlar. Bu
akışların olmaması bizi oldukça zedeler.
Ondan dolayı bu içeriye geldiğimizde de
bu tema ve constant yaparak en azından
belli önce size nasıl kurtaracağınızı
sonra biraz daha advance olan
anlatacağım ve gerçekten o re factor
tamamlayacaksınız. Konuşuyor olacağız.
View mixing yapısı. Şimdi bu benim en
çok bu zamanlarda popüler olarak
önerdiğim hareket bu. Şimdi ne patern
kullanırsanız kullanın arkadaşlar bizim
yapmamız gereken en büyük hareket şu.
Mesela bu flight list page sayfası ya.
Gördüğünüz gibi ben bu flight list
page'de olan build metodunu bulmak için
ta nerelere geliyorum. Bak daha fetch
yaptı falan yaptı filan yaptı. Bakın ben
sayfamın viw'umun yönetecek katmanını
herhangi bir state management kullanarak
burada handle edip kullanabilirim. Tamam
mı? Ama benim asıl handle etmem ve
müşteri veya projenin iyiliği için nokta
şu. Benim flight list page yani bir view
sayfam varsa, view'un da içerisinde
ompressleri, oyu, buyu, şuyu varsa
bunları yönetecek bir katmana daha
ihtiyacım var. Bu state management veya
bir view model seviyesinde değil. V
model'ile vive arasında olacak. Onu da
bir aslında MVP + P yapıyorlardı ama
neyse. Olacak bir katmana ihtiyacımız
var. Burada da arkadaşlar birlikte View
Mixing yapısını çok efektif bir şekilde
kullanarak ki ben o View Mix'in yapısını
birkaç projemde mesela böyle 56lık
katmanlı yaptım. Çok eğlenceli oluyor
tabii birazcık biraz konular advance'e
kaçıyor ama burada view'larımızı
elimizle ben view'a girde sadece view
kodu göreceğim. Yani işini en temiz özet
öyle söyleyeyim. Böyle textler, max'ler,
onlar bunlar bunlar olmayacak. Eee
bunları da konuşuyor olacağız birlikte
arkadaşlar. Şimdi tabii geldik tabii
state management ne kullanılıyor? Burada
hiçbir şey yok mesela. Şimdi state
management kullanım noktasında kontrol
edeceğimiz nokta şu. Şimdi state
management'a neden ihtiyaç duyuyorsunuz?
Mesela bu sayfanın bütün logikleri
çalışıyordur burada ve herhangi bir
state management yok. Çünkü şöyle bir
şey var. Bizim en çok state management
tarzı bir şeye ihtiyaç duymamızın sebebi
aslında projelerdeki global kullanımlar.
Mesela bir basket yapısı, ne bileyim
şuraya geldi, buraya eklendi,
buradakilerin haberleşmesi veya
sayfalarınızın kompleks olmasına göre
bir yerlerden gelen durumları yönetmek
vesaire derken business'la aslında daha
özetleyecek olursam business'la sayfayı
birbirine işler yönetmesi açısından
kullanıyoruz. Şimdi bu noktada iki
kullanım oluyor. Ya view bazlı yani
sayfaların kullandığı bir statement
yöntemi yani sayfanın stateini bir de
global state yönetenler oluyor. Bu iki
kavramı bileceğiz ki bu tarz projelerde
geleceğiz diyeceğiz ki mesela burada ne
kullanılmış? Burada varsa yani herhangi
bir paket yok diye hatırlıyorum burada.
Yani buradakilerin hepsi dümdüz aslında
bakıldığında varsa notifier modifier
vardır. Onun dışında onlar bile olduğunu
düşünmüyorum. dümdüz hani en basic
olarak elle yazılmış şeyler var burada
yani bakıldığında eee yani burada bir
notify belki kullanmıştır dedim de onu
da göremedim. Aşağılarda yaptıysa belki
o vardır. Önemli değil. Yani buradaki
kullandığımız bizim state management
yöntemi veya state management'ta neyi
tercih edeceğimiz noktası da neyi tercih
ettiğiniz de çok önemli olmayacak.
Buradaki önemli olan ihtiyaç ne? Ben
global ve lokal olarak sayfalarımı
kullanacak, yönetecek. Globalde benim
bazı sayfalarda diyelim ki şuradayım.
Yani benim en büyük derdim detaydayım.
Detayın bilmemlerinde zırtında zurtunda.
Buraya geldiğimde ben buraya gelip
şuraya eklemek istemiyorum mesela. Yani
ben oradan bazı şeyleri global objeleri
yöneteceğim ki sayfam benim daha kolay,
daha iyi çalışıyor olacak. Ondan dolayı
aslında state management kontrolündeki
en önemli dikkat etmeli nokta mesela bu
projede birazcık o eksik kalmış. Onu
unutmuşum da işte sayfalar nasıl
yönetilmiş? Bunlar içe mi yazılmış? İşte
burada başka bir şeyler var mı? eee
hangi state management nere yani state
management kullanılmış ama hangileri
kullanılmış? Dispositörü doğru kontrol
edilmiş mi? Eee içerisindeki sayfalar
doğru yerler için mi kullanıyor? Mesela
mesela bir state management yöntemi
kullanıyorsun. En üstten diyelim ki
buradan mesela başlıyorsun işte
sayfaları bilmem ne yapmaya. En üste
mesela bir şey koyuyorsun. En altı zaten
trigger ediyor. Yani bir performans
kalemi kullan. Buradaki en büyük
performans kalemi şu. Mesela şu diyelim
ki user email ve email anlık değişen bir
şey olduğunu varsayalım. Bu sadece o
state'in o variableıyla ilişkili olmalı.
Yani başka türlü bu texte dokunamaması
lazım gibi. Yani bunları da orada yine
konuşuyor olacağız. Navigasyon. Şimdi
tabii ki bu bir mobil projenin aslında
hayatı yani baktığında navigasyondur.
Yani bunun bir şey yok. Mesela bu
projede gördüğünüz gibi navigasyon
hareketleri var. Sağa sola uçuyor falan
filan. Eee bu uçuş hareketlerinde şu an
gördü şu an hiçbir paket yok. Doğrudan
navigator no bilmem ne pop falan deyip
gidiyordur buradan. Eee bakayım
navigator mesela. navigator bilmem ne
yapıyor gidiyor. Şimdi bu bir yöntem.
Gördüğünüz gibi oldukça da aslında eee
kötü olduğunu söyleyebileceğim. Basit.
Daha doğrusu basit. Şimdi bu noktada
şöyle bir şey var. Projenin ihtiyacına
göre bu da seçilebilir. Projenin
ihtiyacı önemli bir nokta. Çünkü üç
sayfalık bir işte kocaman şeylere
girmiyor. Ama biz burada bir gelişmiş ve
bir advance proje konuşuyorsak buradaki
bizim en çok dikkat etmemiz gereken
nokta navigasyonlarda gidecek gelecek
sayfadan gelecek. Hangi sayfadan
gidecek? Hangi sayfadan gelecek? hangi
sayfaya belki girmemesi gerekiyor? Bunu
nasıl yöneteceğiz? Veya buradaki
navigasyon hareketlerindeki tabii ki
deep link'le gelen bir kısmımız da var.
Deep link hareketleri bizi nerelere
götürecek? Buna göre sayfalardaki o
routing'ler bizi nasıl etkileyecek?
Dediğim gibi bunların hepsini
konuşabilmemiz lazım. Şimdi bunları
konuşmak adına da eee projedeki yapıyı
incelediğinde mesela bu projedeki yapıyı
incelediğinde zaten konuşacak bir şey
yok. Zaten elle puhlmış falan filan.
sadece mobil basit bir şey. İçeride de
bunlar vardır. Bu noktanın zaten
yetersiz olduğu ortaya çıkacak. Bu
noktada biz de işte Go routeruyla, Auto
routeruyla neyse artık bir paket
tercihini yapıp eee buradan da ileriye
doğru ilerleyeceğiz.
Navigasyon ama arkadaşlar yani deep
link'le birleştirilmiş navigasyon
gerçekten bu mobil projenin olmazsa
olmaz noktası. Burada da zaten oldukça
eksik. Şimdi generation ve benim en çok
sevdiğim işlemlerden bir tanesi. Yani
ben bu generation'a çok takıntılı bir
adamım. Çok da severek kullanıyorum
çünkü. Yani işte ne bileyim burada
asetlerin elle yazılıyor olması işte
mesela modellerin bu şekilde
mappinglerin böyle yapılması benim hiç
sevdiğim hareketler değil. Şimdi bu
noktada bizim bu proje, bu tarz proje
kullandığımızda yapacağımız hareket şu.
Biz model üretimlerimizi, asetlerimizi
belli başlı paketleri kullanarak zaten
constant seviyesinde olduğu için ya
bunlar zaten değişmeyen şeyler olduğu
için ya da mapperlar, işlemler zaten
bildiğimiz maplemeler olduğu için
parslamalar falan bunları en üstten
yapıyor olacağız ve projeyi bu şekilde
aslında bağımlı veya basic anlamda veya
diyelim ki daha global anlamda hiç
dokunmayacağımız yani maplemeye mesela
bu model mapping'e hiç dokunmazsın. gibi
bunları yapıp projenin en o standart
kısımlarını dışarıya çıkarmış olacağız.
Yani daha bizim dokunmayacağımız yerler.
Buradaki o içeriye geldiğimde advance
olarak size anlatacağım kısım onun daha
optimize nasıl yapacağınızı da konuşup
anlatıyor olacağım.
Eee
ardından arkadaşlar servis katmanı ve
konteyner apps tabii ki yine bir mobil
projenin olmazsa olmaz kısmı bu. Burada
da servis katmanında özellikle
seçeceğiniz paket gideceğiniz ol önemli
burada. En önemli nokta abstraction
bazlı servis katmanlarınızı bütçede
abstraction her yerde var gerçi de
servislerinizde bu moklamaları ve
kullanacağınız instance'ı yapmayı
unutmamak önemli. Interceptorları nasıl
aktif kullandığınız önemli. Çünkü
authorize mesela adam 400 client 401
yedi ne yapacak falan filan. Bunların
hepsini handle edebiliyor muyuz? Ve
doğru servis kısımlarını konta yani
container based yapı kurabiliyor muyuz?
Şöyle mesela benim servis olarak projede
kullandığım bir servis aslında her yerde
onu kullanabiliyor olmam lazım. Bunlar
doğru çalışıyorlar mı? Initişalizer
doğru mu? Bu konteynerlarda ilgili
olarak özellikle burada ekledim ki
birçok projede şey görüyorum işte mesela
user servisini konteyn koymuş ve lazy
koymuş mesela. Ya niye koyuyorsun mesela
kardeşim derim. Onunla ilgili bir örnek
ekleyebilirdik ama unutmuşum. Neyse
zaten yaptığımızda o kısım çıkar. E
çünkü şey yani hani hiç kullanılmıyor
değil. Kullanılmasa problem değil. Öyle
şey olmaz. Yazılımda ihtiyaç varsa her
şeye entegre edilir. Yatay senin user
servisin bir kere entegre ediliyorsa
projenin her yerinden bir en üste
konteynere koyayım. Oradan çekerim.
Çekmezsem yer kaplamıyor gibi bir şey
yapılmaz. İhtiyaç varsa initişaliz
edilir. Yoksa dispoz edilir. Bu kadar.
Yani burada da ondan bahsettim. Eee
modellerden bahsettim. Yine bir mobil
projenin arkadaşlar olmazsa olmaz
noktası modeldir bakıldığında model
isimlendirmeleri modellerin eee
kesinlikle bir immutable olmasına olur.
Bu immutable'lık çok önemli. Çünkü eee
sayfalarda işte bazen işte şurada bir
tane checkbox'a basıyorum. Bir şey
değiştiriyorum. Mesela bu bir
değiştirdiğim şey ilgili modellerde
immutable'deyse şurayı etkileyebilir
veya buradaki data değişikliği doğrudan
projeye bir hani oradaki datanın dispoz
olması buraya referans edebilir. Hani
ondan dolayı elimizden geldiği kadarıyla
bizim alt mobildeki alt modellerimiz
çünkü genelde eee lokal işlemler bizde
olmuyor zaten. Backend'e gidiyoruz
backend güncelliyor. Yani bekendi biz
data veriyoruz yine okuyoruz ama yine de
lokal gerç lokalde de yapıyorsak biz bir
modelimizin bir inutable yani aslında
değişmeyecek ve bunun bir sabitlenmiş
işte eşit eşittir equ table'ların
vesairelerine hazırlanmış tertemiz e
dokunulmayacak istersen copy withle dip
copy işte hl copy alttan al kopyala obje
yenisini oluştur vesaire yap git
yenisini oluşturarak projen de entegre
et diye veriyor olacağız bunu özellikle
en çok mesela sayfaya bir listeniz var
listeye bir tane add yaptınız sonra da
sayfaya bir şey haber vermek
istiyorsunuz ama sayfaya haber
verdiğinde sayfa trigger olmuyor. Çünkü
listeye eklediğiniz şey referans olarak
eklenmiş oluyor. Sayfada var diyor. Yani
onu emit etseyiz de bunu çok
yaşadığımızdan söylüyorum aslında yeni
bir şey görmüyor. Çünkü zaten
referansını sen listeye ekledin. Bunlar
yine böyle başlıklar. Tabii bunları çok
dallanmadan söylüyor olacağım. Konuşuyor
olacağız. Eee modeller konuştuk. Yani
modellerin o mappingleri falan çok
önemli. Onları konuşuyor olacağız.
modüler yapı. Şimdi tabii ki böyle
projelerde arkadaşlar
modülerlik çok önemli. Eee burada da
elimizden geldiği kadar bir modüller
göstereceğim. Mesela nedir modül? işte
core katmanlarının modüle çıkartılması,
servis katmanının bir modüler olarak
belki yazılması, eee veya buradaki bazı
util işlemlerin mesela model
klasörlerinin belki alt modellere
taşınması gibi projenin ihtiyacı olan,
eee, veya projede çok kullanılacak
kısımları ama girilmesini istemediğimiz
yerleri. Mesela diyelim ki burada bir,
eee, third part entegrasyonumuz var.
Doğrudan buraya entegre etmeden de alt
modüllerlik yaparak bu projeye entegre
etmeyi de konuşuyor olacağız. Eee, test
kısmı önemli tabii son şeyde. Şimdi
arkadaşlar, unit test dediğiniz şey, e,
kolay bir yol değildir. Şimdi bu lafta
herkes bir şey yaptığını söylerim. Unit
test dediğiniz şey e abstraction'ın
başında başlar, ileriye doğru ilerler.
Şimdi bu ileriye doğru ilerlemesi için
de senin kodunun buna müsait olması
gerekiyor. Hani o kodu yazdığım
çalışıyor gibi değil. Onun bir sürü
katmanları temiz. Yani ben içerisindeki
birçok obje hani o dependence inversion
dediğimiz hani aslında dataların yani o
içeriseki interface classların da benim
onları moklayabilmem yani objelere
erişmem vesaire bir sürü kavram var.
Şimdi bu kavramları olmadan veya
metotlarınızın içerisinde zaten
parçalanmamış olmadan da neyi test
ediyorsun? Ama mobil'de benim burada en
çok önereceğim şey konuşacağım bir şeyse
bir UI test olacak. Gün test yazmak
çünkü evet advancedir. Bunu konuşuruz
ama bunu mimari belirlemeden önce senin
clean code mimarisini almış olman
gerekiyor. Bu da projeye göre eee alınıp
olmayabilir. Biz onu ayrı başlıkta
konuşuruz. Clean kod var ama biz burada
şunu konuşabiliriz. Kardeşim benim
projem, sayfam çalışıyor. Müşteriye
verdim. CL elimden kadar temizliğini de
yaptım ama eksikleri var biliyorum. Ben
UI testini yazayım ki projemin ben
release versiyonlarına çıkmadan önce bir
test katmanını koysayım. Bu da bana
sağlıklı bir eee viriliz getirsin demiş
olayım. Eee security. Security olmazsa
olmaz bir başlık tabii ki. Security ile
alakalı neler yapabiliriz? Mesela burada
hiçbir şey yok şu an gördüğünüz gibi. Ne
bileyim burada bir initialize var mesela
main dart'ta doğrudan initialize
edilmiş. İşte burada bazı keyler belki
okunması durumu var. Bununla alakalı
birkaç logimiz mesela bunu remote
config'ten okumak belki data okumak
olabilir ama remote config'in işte bir
security anlamında açıkları var. işte
enment'lardan okuma var vesaire. Bunları
neler yapabiliriz? Mobildeki en büyük
security hareketlerini bize ne
kazandırır? Bunları konuşuyor olacağız
bu içerik geldiğinde. Bu içerikte zaten
ya normalde mesela ben bunların hepsini
bir içeride anlatırım da öyle
yapmayacağım. Belki şunu anlatacağım. 5
dakikada videoyu kapatacağım. Çünkü ben
hepsini anlatınca sonuna kimse gelmiyor.
Üzülüyorum.
En azından parça parça anlatak da
sıkılmay sıkılanı da anlıyorum ama r
sıkılacak bir şey yok. Burada teknik
anlatıyorsun. Eee, şimdi buradan en
önemli açlıklardan bir tanesi yine
script. Bu da önemli çünkü projenin
mesela işte language'leri, build
olmaları, birçok scriptleri olabiliyor.
Bunları da hazırlarsak yarın projeye
girdiğinizde bir daha bir daha bazı
şeyleri tek tek nasıldı falan
uğraşmazsınız. Bunlarla ilgili third
partlar var. Vereceğim. İşte Google
runnerların kullanımı falan. Bunlarla
ilgili scriptler var. Bunları buradan
entegre ediyor olacağız birlikte. Eee,
başka neyimiz var?
publish süreçleri. Yani son olarak iki
kısım diyeyim. Daha da artar bu arada da
ben şu an böyle bıraktım. Public
süreçleri önemli. Burada en basitinden
bir Fay altyapısı kurgulayıp bu Fin
altyapısı kurgularken neye dikkat
etmeliyizi konuşarak devam edeceğiz.
Burada tabii Flavor'ın olması çok
önemli. En azından projemizin
development ortamını ben genelde şöyle
öneriyorum. Eee projenizin development
ortamını Firebase'de tutun. Çünkü Fireb
hızlı bir şekilde paket çıkıp
getirebiliyor. E production ortamını
test flight ve App Store'lara alın gibi.
Bu publish süreçlerine de işte mesela
paket çıkmadan önce bir ufak dart komutu
çalıştırıp işte mesela buyurt olmayan
bir proje mesela ben bu birkaç defa
böyle hatay yaptım. Mesela benim
pipeline'ımda yoktu. 20 dakika bu
söylüyor işte. 20 dakika niye sürüyor?
Çünkü flutter indiriyor bilmem ne bilmem
ne. Son dakikaya geliyor. Hata olarak
şey diyor işte projede bir tane build
var. İşte bir dosya eee yanlış yazılmış.
Ya bunun aslında en başta bu
anlaşılabilir. Ondan dolayı scriptinizin
publish süreçlerinizi gitap'la belki
burada ne anlatırım onu tam düşünmedim.
Şu an da gitabını falan anlatırsam gitub
actionlarla bir ufak hareket yapar.
Orayı konuşuruz ama bu başlığı da
önemsemek geçen de bir yazı paylaşmıştım
önemli. Yani son olarak arkadaşlar
böyle proje yapıyorsanız
ve e projeyi faktör edecekseniz ben
yaptım ben gidiyorum diyerek ben çok
kolay bu işi yaparım zaten. Mevzu bahis
bensiz ve eee aslında yarın proje
dünyaya çıktığında herkesin girebileceği
bir iş yapmak. Bunu şu maddelerle
yaparsanız zaten projenizin kodunu gören
bir insan ne yapacağını nereye
gideceğini zaten aykırıyor. Ya bundan
yana problem yok. Ama yine bir projenin
olmazsa olmazı aslında bir best practice
yoludur. Yani mesela nedir? Bu best
practice yolu da çok basittir aslında.
Ne yapmak lazım? Bu detaylar sayfasını
referans alalım. Detaylar sayfasında ne
vardır? Servis isteği vardır. Detaylar
sayfasında navigasyon vardır. Detaylar
sayfasında bir view standartı vardır.
Değil mi? Bunu alırsın arkadaşlar. bir
dokümantasyona çevirirsin. View açarken
işte bunu bunu mixing yapmak style
guideı bu bunu bu buradan okunur. İşte
routing yapıyorsan işte otor router
bilmem ne yapılır. Butona basıyorsan
bunlar yapılır. Sayfa böyle açılır.
Sayfa buradan gelir. Bu practisi kendi
takımına bir dokümantasyonla
hazırlarsın. Bu dokümantasyon bittiğinde
bu takıma verirsin. Takımdaki herkese de
buna uyması için diktesini yaparsın.
Bununla ilgili gerekirse bir prompt da
oluşturursun. Tabii bu prompta gelir.
Eee, senin projen için rahatlıkla bir
standart belirlemiş olur. Yani eee,
tabii ki dediğim gibi daha fazla
konuşacağım başlıklar projenin durumuna
göre. Şimdi bazı şeyler tabii ki afaki
kalabilir. Bu proje çok gerçekçi bir
proje değil sonuçta. Hani en azından
backend falan yaptık ama daha gerçekçi
projede daha farklı konuşmalarım oluyor.
Eee, bu proje bu tarz bir fikri almanız
ama bence e çok önemli. Çünkü mesela bu
e çağında tabii ki bunların hepsini
verseniz bir şeyler çıkartacak size ama
niye çıkardığını, ne yapmanız
gerektiğini veya çıkardığında acaba bunu
yanlış mı yaptığı anlama adına ya da bir
projeye girdiğinizde dediğim gibi hemen
bir pub şey abi state management paketi
senin çok kötüymüş işte seninki provider
çok kötü o işe yaramıyor falan
demektense olayın ne olduğunu anlamaya
içeriye odaklamaya e ve projeyi daha
ilere götürmeyi aslında birlikte
konuşuyor eee entegre ediyor. diyor ve
eee yapıyor olacağız. Bunları da zaten
arkadaşlar birlikte projenin ilerleme
durumlarına göre eee konuşacağız. Devam
edeceğiz. Burada başka bir şey var
mıdır? Şöyle düşündüm. Başka
ekleyeceğimiz başka bir şey yoktur.
Şurada belki bir de eee loging şey
talker şöyle yapayım talk vs loging
işlemleri bakılacak. Yani burada bir
tane başlık olarak da arkadaşlar
projenin işte development ortamında test
yapılırken nasıl test edileceği vesaire
bloglama işlemleri dönemli başlık. Onu
da burada işliyor olacağız. Böyle bir
içerik serisini arkadaşlar haftalık
olarak önümüzdeki hafta itibariyle küçük
küçük çeke çeke bu bu eee yani şeyi de
bu app'i de aslında fixleyerek eee size
gösteriyor olacağım. Umarım size burada
bir birlikte bir yardım ve fikir
verebiliyor olacağım. E ardından da
zaten geri kalanların arkadaşlar
birlikte eee konu bakta sesi gelmiş onu
silmek lazım da neyse şimdi gitsin
silerim onları ben. Eee konuşuyor
olacağız arkadaşlar. E şimdiden eee
güzel bir içeriye geldiğinizi
söyleyebilirim. parça parça hepsini
anlatıyor olacağım zaten. Umarım siz de
buradan kendi projenize göre, eee, kendi
işinize göre birtım yollar, birtım
routingler çıkartırsınız ve buna göre,
eee, kodunuzu, projenizi
güzelleştirirsiniz demiş olayım. Artık
devamındaki içeriklerde arkadaşlar
birlikte görüşmek üzere diyorum.
Kendinize iyi bakın arkadaşlar. Eee, bol
şanslar hayatta. Görüşmek üzere bir
sonraki videolarda.